many times when you look at a very
successful business from the outside it
looks like everything's going perfect
like there should be zero problems but
in order for a company to become
successful they got to do the ugly
things very good behind closed doors
that nobody sees and one of the ugliest
things you'll ever have to do as a
leader as a boss as a CEO as a c-type
executive as whoever it is that's
running a department is firing people
and today I'm going to talk to you about
how to fire a teammate someone or an
employee part of your company before I
get into anything I'm going to cover
here with you I want you to keep a
couple things in mind
you got to follow your state and your
country's human resource HR rules and
guidelines that the apps or whatever I
tell you your laws go first
these are just simple philosophies on
things that can help you with your
business okay so look I've been around
the block for a while I've hired and
fired so many different people and the
first time is always a difficult one
it's very similar to closest a
correlation I can give you to what it is
to fire somebody is when you're breaking
up with somebody it's always good if
somebody has broken up with someone and
someone else has broken up with you if
you have experience on both sides you
will know when somebody broke up with
you hurt and then you will know when you
broke up with somebody what their
reaction was and if there really is a
general consensus to how things should
be the goal is you want to finish things
amicably right so you know the typical
breakup line is what's the famous
breakup line when somebody wants to
break up we all know it you know honey
it's really not you it's it's me I'm the
problem right over here something that
says I just don't see this thing going
in the direction we want it to go today
we both know this day was coming or
whatever it is right we have all these
breakup lines firing is also got some
lines but I think it's very important to
know you're dealing with a human being
and if the first thing you think about
is you're dealing with a human being
you'll take the approach in a complete
different way then looking at someone
else let me just fire this person
because it's robotic you're still
dealing with a human being so 11 points
I'll cover with you we'll help you out
before I get into that as well
one of the biggest reasons why you have
to put yourself in a position to fire
somebody is because you didn't properly
hire somebody so what do you mean you
didn't properly hire somebody why don't
we talk about that first so Penn what do
you mean don't hire some we didn't hire
somebody properly but you call
references
what type of references did you call
many spoke to them did they go and talk
to some other people to see if their
personality is going to fit the culture
did you just hire them because you like
them a lot bet they have zero skill set
did you do a background check on them to
see about anything that they have going
on did you ask the proper question when
they say oh I've taken a sabbatical for
two years I haven't worked is that
really the case or is that a script some
people say when for the last two years
they have had a job but it didn't finish
well and they don't want you to call the
job because you don't want the reference
maybe they didn't quit the job maybe
they were fired maybe to have some bad
things they don't want to tell you about
any time somebody's got a long gap and
work there's a concern there's a red
flag so you got to ask those types of
questions and once you ask those types
of question then you hire sometimes you
also try to force someones talent into a
job that they're not a part of our cover
that as well you got to figure out who
the person is do they fit the position
then you hired them so above anything
the rule that I live by when it comes on
to hiring and firing is hire very slow
fire extremely fast how you're very slow
fire extremely fast there's nothing
worse than a boyfriend and a girlfriend
being in a relationship that they know
is never ever going to work out but they
just keep dragging it out and it just
keeps wasting both of the people's lives
I've done it many people do it there's
no need for it when it comes on to
business so let's cover the 11 different
points that I have here so rule number
one
first things first when it comes down to
fire somebody the goal is to fire them
gently period the goal is to fire them
gently what does this mean fire them
gently didn't work out they leave you're
happy they're happy no more I can't
believe this is what happened I can't
believe that is what happened your goal
is to fire gently there doesn't need to
be any kind of retaliation on both sides
because the employee
your can obviously hurt the employee and
the employee can obviously hurt the
employer so if anybody starts at both
way it's not going to be pretty and it's
not going to help the courier why is it
not going to help the curry because if
the employer bashes the employee there
is no employees don't want to work for
the employer because everybody that
works for this company if you're leaving
in a bass shoe and the employee doesn't
want to bash the employer because no
matter other place you go to doing the
worst things I like to hear in an
interview is what when somebody is
sitting there and I'm interviewing them
and the employee keeps bashing the prior
two companies they work for the
companies are not the problems generally
it's the person who's the problem it's
not necessarily always the company so a
person says all my last boss was this my
last boss was this we already see a sign
of that so as somebody that's hired a
lot of people that's a red flag when I'm
looking at hiring somebody so the goal
is that people go gently look I have a
daughter one day my daughter is going to
date a man and they're going to go on
their first date and then she's gonna
have a boyfriend okay now my daughter is
right now four months old so that's not
coming for at least 40 more years right
he's gonna take her time for going to
having a boyfriend but when that day
comes and she has a boyfriend and then
there's a breakup okay as a father and
my personality is extremely
overprotective and I have access to the
resources to money I know people from
all over the place there's a lot of
different resources that I have access
to my goal is for that breakup to be
what to be as amicable as possible in
the for the boyfriend to not go bashing
and saying things and my daughter to not
do either
none of them hey they don't work out
they don't work you guys go your
separate ways
that's your outcome with 99.9% of the
people you fire that's your outcome now
what's the point one percent if the
point one percent this person wants to
breach the contract and they want to go
out there and do something that's going
to hurt the company well it's
unfortunate but this is what general
counsel and legal counsel comes in and I
won't get into it I've been on both
sides of the aisle myself I know exactly
what it is to be on both on both sides
so I know the experiences but that's
when it's 2.1% and when the point 1%
takes place you got to make sure you do
something to protect your company you
work very hard for if somebody this has
to go that route
but that rarely happens very very rarely
does that ever happen point number two
when you're firing somebody get to the
point don't drag it out now there's
nothing more annoying than a drag-out
breakup hey this is not working out
here's why okay I want to get right into
it
I don't like firing anybody that's a
part of the business I don't like but
this is just not working up to the point
okay and as you're going through it
there may be a part there's a shock
factor to the person that you're at
Amaury I'm not pointing at you because
we're firing him just just looking at
you here in case there's a shock factor
to somebody you fire so you know the
shock factor is oh my gosh I you know
what do you mean what do you and so
there may be the opportunity for them to
say but I thought this I thought it's
working out I thought this you don't
need to defend yourself because if
you're firing somebody when it gets to
that point you have already done your
proper homework especially after
watching this video where you're not
firing because you're winging it you're
firing because there's a lot of other
things you're going to do before you
fire somebody so you need to stay firm
the next point is stay firm as you're
firing somebody so gently get to the
point
stay firm don't defend why you're firing
don't defend you know constantly with
them going back and forth this is not a
debate this is a decision we're not
debating here this is a decision that's
been made you're fired
you need to move on and this just didn't
work out gentle clear to the point firm
and then after that part acknowledge
their feelings listen I understand if
this may be a bit of a frustrating
moment for you I understand this may be
a disappointing moment for you I've been
fired before and I can tell you it's not
very exciting when this happens however
I just want to make sure I totally
understand your feelings on what you're
thinking about okay next
typically the protocol I like to follow
is exit interview is always done by the
person who hired them if I hired Mario
I'm firing Mario you don't give your
dirty work to somebody else if you hired
somebody and you were the person that
said we have made a decision to give you
the position you need to make sure
you're doing the firing now let's just
say if you need
hiring but they worked under John who
runs that entire department then it's
you and John together in the room
talking to the person that's getting
fired okay both people but there needs
to be an exit interview sometimes people
do firing in a ways that's just you know
you just got to do it and take care of
it and this is not a way to hurt
somebody you want to make sure it's done
in a proper way that they're kunai
you're dealing with a somebody who's a
vendor or somebody who is a independent
contractor that's helping you out with
your IT services and you're firing
bobbies you're gonna fire them over the
phone you know or something like that
but if you're dealing with somebody
that's in house team you're doing it
face to face okay next
generally it also shouldn't be a
surprise this is point number six it
shouldn't be a surprise let me explain
what I mean by that generally it
shouldn't be a surprise and here's why
it shouldn't be a surprise it shouldn't
be a surprise because throughout the
process let you say bob has work with me
for 60 days and within the first week
two weeks three weeks four weeks I will
generally no areas that I'm not happy
with Bob and I'll say Bob this is very
important and this was part of your what
we hired when we hired you on the
application it explained your job
description I want to highlight this as
part of your job description so I'm
going back to the job description that I
put up important if you don't have a
clear job description out front then
they can come back and say well you
never told me this was part of my job
description so they're held accountable
to what the job description you can tell
the job description here and you're not
doing this right you told me you type 65
words per minute but it looks like
you're typing 35 words per minute
you told me your spelling is right but
there's seven and eight different
spelling errors you in this email you're
sending to a customer that you know what
happened you tell me about it do you
really know okay well here's what I want
you to do once you write this out or
whatever you do some testing you do some
accountability in coaching right so if
it happens again another time and you
say wow this really needs to improve if
it doesn't it's part of your job
description if it happens again or Bob
you told me you're somebody that shows
up on time three times in the last two
weeks you've been late and I know and
they said but it's only eight minutes
eight minutes
eight minutes is eight minutes is a long
time but you're still a three times in
the last two weeks and we you said
you're punctual and we're expecting
people that are you're punctual I just
want you to know if that continues
that's going to be a challenge so let's
just say those two have those two things
continue right when it comes down to
firing them they're not sitting there as
a surprise because you're going to say
John I don't think this about I don't
think this is going to be surprised to
you because you know when you got
started we're late three times in two
weeks and I told you that's an issue and
this has happened again three more times
in the last four weeks so we just have
to let you go okay
bomb to the point see how easy that was
you're getting to the point hey look you
know one of the job descriptions and I
brought this up to you several times
what you need to be working faster you
tell me you work in a very pressure type
situations but it seems like a couple
times when it was you're hitting
deadlines you didn't perform well during
deadlines and this happened on three
different occasions and that's very
important to us and we just have to let
you know we have to let you go and I'm
sure it's not a surprise because this
has been brought up so if you do it
properly while you're going through the
probationary period and you're telling
them areas they need to improve in
there's not going to be a surprise when
it happens and many times they'll even
know that it's getting to a point that
this may not work out many times they'll
quit before you're gonna fire them it's
the same thing if you do improper thing
of accountability
it'll get to pumper they'll say you know
what honestly I just I just don't think
I fit you know I'm just really trying
and really doing this and really not
just not going to work for me no problem
totally understand boom all good we let
you go it's it's a lot easier sometimes
you want the other person to break up
with you right because you don't want to
break the heart and some time with the
other girl or guy comes and says I just
can't see this going along and back your
mind your same thing god you just said
it you're right I wish it would but
you're right let's just move on I agree
so that happens as well so that happens
is what many times when you're going
through that so that areas covered that
areas covered okay perfect so next one
next one is as you're doing the exit
interview here's what I like to ask
I used to 13 years ago get right into
giving feedback on why I'm firing some
people don't want it some people don't
want it and they're offended now I ask
do I have your permission to give you
some feedback this is
exit interview would you like some
feedback yes I would like to get I would
like to get some feedback from you when
you are giving feedback I cover feedback
in a couple different ways
I cover and my feedback is extremely
intentional because I have one outcome
with me letting you go my goal is for
you to leave me and do 10 times better
than you did while you were with me
that's my goal
when I let an employee go and it didn't
work out I want you to go be successful
I want you to go out and go make money I
don't want you to stand unemployment I
want you to go figure out a way to make
money so I'll say look there's a couple
things I want you to know about one of
the things I want you to know about it
just seems like you're always late
secondly I want you to know about it
just seems like you don't follow details
and details is not your game or third
thing is your customer service needs
some work the way you talk to people you
know this is a cus if you're planning on
being in a part of the business where
you touching a customer that's got to
improve so you may need to be the
behind-the-scenes type of a person that
you're not touching a customer that's
okay they don't need to see you but if
you're going to be touching customers
that's got to improve or it could be
another thing where look if you don't
know something don't tell people you
know three times you told me you know
that you didn't know it and it kind of
it you lost credibility with me in the
future I'm a lot more comfortable with
the person telling me Patrick honest you
don't know but can you give me a day to
learn about it
I like that response why don't you use
that a response on your next company
that's a great idea and they'll take
notes perfect any questions you have for
me boom but you're giving feedback there
and you talk about their strengths
because there isn't anybody you'll ever
fire that does not have strengths so
when you say I can't really think about
anything positive to say about this
person
everybody everybody I've ever fired
they've always had strengths it just
didn't work out for many different
reasons so you do want to highlight
their strengths that they have as well
okay you know I remember one time I had
an employee ok this was this was what
your Mario 506 and when it's over I
might give his nickname the right people
know what his nickname is his nickname
is hoot and he loves the fact that I
mentioned
his name in this video I won't give his
full name okay first of all I love this
guy he is probably one of my if not my
favorite assistant of all time who at
the same time was by far probably the
worst assistant ever in the history of
assistants
this guy was terrible he was horrible
and I dragged it out for eight months I
think it's more because I loved him he's
like my younger brother and he was
terrible at it I mean things would never
get done he was never organized I was
telling him what to do every single day
wasn't the relationship was the other
way around but he liked to you know be
around my cars he we would hang out he
would listen to the stuff we were
driving the cars would go places
together so it was always good he was
very good at making sure the oil change
was done properly though he was very
very good in that part of it one day I
sat him down and I said who died got to
tell you this man and he knew it was
coming I said who buddy I got good news
I got bad news what do you want to know
he says he's pad I know what it is but
tell me the bad news I said bad news is
you are terrible my gosh you are
terrible at being an assistant he says
what's the good news
I says you have no idea how much I trust
you I trust you you are such a kind
human being people love being around you
but you're not a good assistant and I
will tell you this sometimes people who
don't make good assistants they make
very good entrepreneurs they make very
good independent contractors they make
very good in a complete different area
so this is not a bad thing but I said
what do you want to do with your life
and we went through a conversation to
get I said listen tell me what you want
to do in your life this is fat honestly
I love surfing I said okay so what's
your point with surf and many people
officer says no I really love surfing I
said okay tell me what you really love
about so you went into it I said so why
don't you go travel the world and go
surf all the places you want to surf
you're 21 years old he says you think I
can really do now see ya go work all
over the place and go surfer what places
you want to services I want to surf in
this place I want to surf in New Zealand
I want to surf in Australia I want to
serpent you know what he went through
all these places in the world he wants
to serve do you know what he did for the
next ten years he wanted surfed at all
these places he lit
early lives there he lived in all of
these places China some strange places
in the world anyone surfing and you know
how I made his money he made his money
teaching other people how to surf at the
beach
while he was surfing so while teaching
other people how to serve and working at
restaurant he was surfing and he got
that out of his system but I'm so happy
for him because he was able to go and
pursue what he wanted to with his life
he was a terrible assistant ok
till today very good relationship if he
comes and sees me or my kids he can
spend the night at our house he's like
family to me and he's probably watching
this right now cracking up and who do
you want the first to comment on this
hoots much loved you much much love too
from me and everybody else to you number
eight don't drag it out do not drag out
firing somebody if you're going to fire
somebody you already know that they need
to be fired
don't wait two more months don't wait
four more months it's probably not going
to change if the things are very very
things that are very very important for
that job to be done it's probably not
going to change you need to fire them
and you need to fire them now is what
you need to be doing if there are things
that you don't necessarily see improving
a lot but some of you're going to watch
it so you're going to say I have to go
fire these three people
wait have you given them already the
feedback on those areas you need to
improve and have you given them to for
six weeks to see if there's going to be
progress on it if you have gone all
through all of these then fire them
don't get off this video and just go
someone to be in this firing when I'm on
a fire every single person I see on my
office here then you'll have nobody left
and you'll go out of business you don't
want to do that but once you realize who
it is you got to make sure you'll drag
this entire process out nine I already
told you kind of earlier hire slow fire
fast ten always when you hire people
have a 120 day probationary period
sometimes 90 days sometimes 120 days
which means you're getting an
opportunity here to work with us for 90
days we will decide within the next 90
days if you'll stay with us but this is
probationary period at any point we can
decide to go to a different direction
are you comfortable with that yes
perfect come onboard and we give the 90
days you're 90 days going to be August
1st your 90 day is going to be July 1st
we just want you to know during this 90
days we're going to learn a lot about
each other you comfortable with that yes
perfect so then while you're firing you
got also be prepared
to have a plan for replacement you need
to replace this person that is no longer
with you so there needs to be a plan of
replacement sometimes you can do it
properly with that person that's going
to be leaving trains the replacement
they train the replacement and there's
nothing like that if you do it properly
train the replacement we just have to do
that recently yourself and there was a
process of training the replacement if
there isn't a training for the
replacement and you're going to be out
with somebody that needs to know what
they're doing for that two to four week
period you don't want to be doing that
right or if it's somebody that you just
hired and it's only been a month you can
fire them because they can't train the
next person anyway right so it's very
very important very very important for
you to know also that you have a
replacement in mind so with that being
said this is probably not the most
exciting subject but many of you keep
asking me about how I fire people and
how you can go out and fire someone
properly as an employed an employer or
team member this is how I've done it
over the years and it's gotten better
and better over the years it becomes
very clear once you have a philosophy in
place on how you do it it becomes very
easy but the key is when you're building
a team if you don't build a team full of
talented people
your constant going to be firing a lot
of people they don't really know what
they're doing
hire properly and you won't have to fire
too often because it's never pretty it's
very annoying so with that being said
Mari where's my favorite pillow buddy
let's send that over here okay we now
have a goal there's somebody catch it
huh we now have a goal I normally say
hundred thousand subs but now we're
trying to get to quarter million subs by
when June 1st of 2017 I know it's a long
ways from now but we've done the math
June 1st and we're totally okay we're
hitting a sooner we believe we're going
to hit a sooner broad goals to get to a
quarter million subs be sure to click on
the button and subscribe easier catch
you just sitting there it's like you
think in your Odell Beckham the way you
cut it just a simple catch it's called a
good quarterback threw it to you right
instead of throwing it all the way in
the bottom here so I'm Pat Brady so I'm
re then played American football he
confuses sometimes he plays soccer and
he's actually pretty good at playing
soccer one time I took Mario to soccer
Li
and it was a bunch of nice people mario
ends up tackling the main guy who was a
senior pastor of this entire
organization and he gets up looks at him
what is at the ground and talk smack to
him and then they say why don't you
bring this guy X admit it's competitive
man what can I do about that
so anyways subscribe got any questions
or comments about this comment on the
bottom if you got questions about the
subject and with that being said thanks
for watching everybody take care bye